I mentioned on yesterday's show that
there's an opinion piece in the Los
Angeles Times by John Wiener which says
that 2019 is going to be the worst year
of Donald Trump's life we now know that
trumps personal and political and
professional lives all appear to contain
criminality they are all under
investigation and it's very quickly
going to get much worse because as I
mentioned at the top of the show House
Democrats have been sworn into power
with Nancy Pelosi as Speaker of the
House after huge wins quite frankly in
the 2018 midterm elections the new
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi third
in line for the presidency said in an
NBC interview with Savannah Guthrie in
the last 48 hours I played it yesterday
she's not ruling out impeachment nor
indictment of President Donald Trump
Democratic congressman Jerry Nadler from
New York the new chairman of the House
Judiciary Committee said that House
Democrats will use their subpoena power
if necessary to get the answers that
they want to get investigations are very
quickly launching in this new house into
Trump's targeting of immigrants and
migrants into adding a citizenship
question to the 2020 census congressman
Elijah Cummings is looking into the
security clearance Fiasco involving
Michael Flynn and Jared Kushner and many
others Cummings along with congressman
peter defazio
will be looking into trump's involvement
in not moving the FBI headquarters as
part of the House Transportation and
Infrastructure Committee you then have
the House Ways and Means Committee
already starting to work on obtaining
Donald Trump's tax returns something I'd
be very interested in looking at and
note that this is all separate from
Russia investigations happening at the
criminal and political levels into the
Trump Tower meeting campaign finance
violations obstruction of justice
witness tampering everything I'm
mentioning today Pat is separate from
the storm that is starting to now rain
down on Donald Trump yeah it's all good
stuff I do think that we're going to
learn quite a lot because the house is
going to have resources at their
disposal that members of the media don't
necessarily have so we can learn a lot
of new information
though is it going to move the needle is
it going to affect Trump supporters at
all and make him less popular in the
polls we don't know and the answer is
maybe not and that's why we need to
ignore them and no matter what happens
with any of these investigations the
time that we have to do activism is far
better spent getting people to vote who
are already sympathetic to our side the
side of reason and logic and morality
and common sense than trying to convince
Trump is because many of them are a lost
cause and then lastly by the way the
emoluments Clause to the Constitution of
the United States Trump receiving things
of value from foreign powers that's an
entirely unique and separate line of
inquiry which is also going to be
undertaken it is really difficult as Pat
is pointing out to get presidents to
face consequences for their actions
but if it's going to happen this is a
great opportunity for it one of the most
criminal administration's in a very long
time now being subject to the
investigative power of the opposing
party which has taken control of the
House of Representatives and notably we
may get to see transcripts from the
congressional testimony given during the
last Congress by Jared Kushner
and Donald Trump jr. and Roger stone
what did they say how much did they lie
based on the information we've gotten
since their testimony Adam Schiff says
he is interested in releasing some of
those transcripts I hope we get them
these are going to be very very
interesting 2 years what are you most
looking forward to under this new
democratically controlled house let me
know on Twitter at D Pakman also make
sure to follow the show on twitter at
david pakman show one of the day's
sponsors is privacy dot-com slash Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card
so that it's not spread all over the
Internet and one of the best things
about it is how their mobile app and
browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a david pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link